i'm jane secker and this is the last and
final episode of storycast 21.
when we set out to make this series we
asked our journalists and producers to
share with us the one story they worked
on which has stayed with them more than
any other this century
the responses were many and varied and
we took from these ideas to bring you a
selection of personal stories from just
some of the century's biggest news
events
but 21 years ago as we readied ourselves
for this new century we found ourselves
reporting on what was then expected to
be the biggest story of our times
something not unlike the covert 19
pandemic of today and that this story
had the potential to impact everyone all
across the world
the very first story of 2000 revolved
around what was then a worldwide effort
to combat a global computer bug
episode 21 of storycast 21 tells one
man's story from that crisis
this is the y2k prison bug
[Music]
the so-called year 2000 computer bug has
generated fears that anything from
nuclear missiles to interbank trading
systems could fail when 1999 turns into
the year 2000
my name is rob mulhern and i'm the
series producer of sky news storycast
back in december 1999 people were pretty
nervous about the dawn of a new
millennium
experts had long been predicting that on
the stroke of midnight on the 1st of
january 2000
the computers that managed not only our
economies but our lives
would fail
[Applause]
the problem is systems thinking 0-0 the
shorthand for 2000 is instead 1900.
organizations have spent months and
years aiming to avoid this
no one it seemed taught to program
computers to recognize dates beyond the
31st of december 1999. often they
thought it was 1980 or 1976
and sometimes those systems didn't
handle that change very well at all and
crashed
this is matthew hackling he's a cyber
security consultant from perth
and back in 1999 i myself was living in
australia
among the first major economies
set to experience the millennium day
change
failing to guard against the problem is
threatening to bring the country to a
standstill from telecommunications to
banking
i remember vividly the australian
government taking y2k really seriously
how the collapse of computer systems may
lead get this
to the collapse of civilization itself
and as well as the threats to the
economy there were huge concerns around
law and order
and one area in particular
in an australian prison there's really
not that many prison officers on the
facility they use technologies to detect
people breaking in and people breaking
out and wouldn't really want the doors
on the most secure facility to pop open
on new year's eve
back in 1999
matthew hackling was handed one of the
toughest jobs of the entire y2k crisis
fixing the computer book that was set to
throw into chaos the australian prison
system
thereby handing inmates a possible
escape
the countdown was on
[Music]
you might expect a solution to a future
national computer crisis to begin in an
i.t lab somewhere
but the road to solving this programming
problem actually started in the quiet
suburban bedroom of matthew's home in
perth western australia
i was very much into computers from a
young age
both my parents are academics and so i
grew up on university networks
my mother was a mainframe operator for
the university of western australia
i used to play online games
with uni students when i was you know
knee-high
despite the fact that matthew was still
just a kid in the 1980s
he quickly went from playing games to
making them
when i was a kid one of the first
programs that i programmed was
coded in from a magazine and it was like
a little game where you flew a spaceship
um down like a ravine and didn't crash
into the walls
and um yeah i was pretty impressed with
myself when i got that to work
matthew's love of computers it stayed
with him through his teenage years
by 1997 he did a university degree in
i.t and security management
and by 1999 when computers pretty much
ran everything in the world
matthew had found himself in a
specialist role with the ministry of
justice his job securing australia's
toughest prison
as well as the countless economic issues
thrown up by the millennium bug
and in terms of this story
the government of western australia were
now in a race against time to try and
make their j of y2k compliant
so the worst case scenario for a maximum
security prison would be of course like
somebody breaking in to break out
prisoners
when things went a little bit haywire or
a prisoners organizing a prison break
it was now
nine months to go to the day change
matthew's first major assignment
actually turned out to be the state's
toughest jail
casarina prison
located on the outskirts of perth
and the scene of a christmas day prison
riot only months before
[Music]
the one that always sticks in my mind is
kasharina
prison because uh that's the um with the
premier maximum security prison in
western australia
but uh yeah it is kind of like in a kind
of arid
dusty sandy area
and um it has very high razor wire
fences
there is uh you know
uh you know armed response vehicles that
patrol the perimeter of the prison
and the perimeter of the prison does not
have a break in it the um the gatehouse
is actually underneath the um the razor
wire
and that's designed for you know maximum
security
and i tell you what it's pretty spooky
going into that facility the first time
especially when you do this long long
walk from the gatehouse to the
to the center of the prison
[Music]
we hear is the whistle of the wind
through the reservoir
and is very eerie eerie feeling
because cassarina prison was home to
some of australia's most dangerous
criminals
security depended as much on the 24-hour
surveillance cameras as the prison
guards
in simple terms
this technology was controlled by a
network of clocks and timers
that opened and shut cell doors that
turned on and off cameras
so all those sort of systems be they you
know closed
detection systems or access control
systems intrusion detection
they all work on you know on computer
systems and embedded systems
if it came to pass that these clocks
stopped working when the date changed
from 1999 to 2000
well
this may inadvertently hand thousands of
prisoners the chance of an escape
in any maximum security prison where you
know people are getting locked up for
you know multiple decades for doing
really bad type stuff
yeah they're always looking for a way to
get out so
but if the security problem in katarina
were to be dealt with properly then
matthew and his fellow team of engineers
would themselves need to be locked
inside
we had as built drawings show where all
the
field equipment was throughout the
prison but we really didn't know whether
there were clocks in them or not
only then
could they set off in search of the
clocks and timers that needed to be
fixed so as to prevent against
jailbreaks
when i was in the prison a lot of the
sort of the the technologies they're
hidden away from the inmates um you know
in roof spaces or in equipment cabinets
so there was a lot of sort of you know
getting into places with dusty places
that people hadn't been to for a while
that they didn't have a clock in them
and yeah and so yeah i did you did end
up crawling through a lot of a lot of
roof spaces because that's where we put
a lot of security technologies and so it
was really an activity of you know
writing down serial numbers and model
numbers of devices and performing
inventory
and what we did is if it had a clock in
it then we sort of we tested it
the difficulty is even though all this
work has been done on the millennium bug
it remains in many areas an issue of
public confidence
weeks quickly turned into months and as
matthew said about his work in casarina
and the other maximum security prisons
in western australia
beyond the prison walls
public anxiety around the y2k crisis
continue to ramp up
airlines show 13 at some risk
remarkable as it might sound planes
falling from the sky and bank accounts
being wiped if their balances
were among the chief concerns both
domestically and internationally eight
major financial institutions also face
severe risk but if y2k was starting to
feel like a bad science fiction movie
then matthew who by now believed he
tracked down nearly all the prison
security systems
was finding that work on the ground in
one of the assigned maximum security
prisons was anything but
yeah we
actually
had some issues with a cell intercom
system
and these systems are in cells so that
our prisoners can press a button and
talk to a guard in the gatehouse
when we rolled the system over to 2000
at this prison all the cell intercom
systems went off
the system clocked over to 1980
[Music]
it was for this very situation that the
ministry of justice hired matthew
a situation where prison guards
outnumbered by prisoners
may well find themselves cut off and
unable to communicate
not just with inmates but more
critically each other
a nightmare scenario however remote
already it was apparent to lots of
prisoners and some with no hope of ever
being released that the y2k bug could
well compromise security in their
individual prison and um yeah that was
um
that was unexpected
and uh what we ended up doing is we
ended up upgrading that system
to newer firmware on the field equipment
so that it would work properly after the
ytk turnover
against this backdrop well it wouldn't
be entirely accurate to say the ministry
of justice had complete faith in the
security upgrade work
in a maximum security prison you know
there are people who are armed on-site
the moj did have a lot of sort of
contingency planning and they did sort
of run you know
a crisis management type activity and
you know
i suspect they might have put a few
people like extra people on um for you
know for the ytk shift no one was just
sort of crossing their fingers and you
know hoping that everything would work
out all right
by now spring had given way to summer in
australia and little by little prism
wing by prison wing matthew and his
colleagues had completed the upgrade
work in not only casarina
but western australia's other maximum
security prisons there's also growing
concern
systems will experience computer
breakdowns in the year 2000
by now
dramatic y2k news reports from across
the world were impossible to avoid
across the world billions of pounds been
spent on making computers y2k compliant
perhaps none's more important than the
computers that run the nuclear bunkers
of russia and america
waking up on new year's eve against the
backdrop of reports like that one
citing possible nuclear armageddon
matthew took comfort in the fact that
he'd found every clock he'd fixed every
timer
at least he hoped so i had a lot of a
bit of professional sort of um you know
curiosity is like did we really get
everything well you know well you know
if we didn't get everything it couldn't
be a system that was now critical
[Music]
either way the ministry of justice was
now mere minutes and thousands of alert
prisoners away
from the final countdown of the
millennium
and um my wife was actually drumming in
a samba band
[Music]
i joined her marching through the
streets of perth
to a party on top of a building in the
subiaco
[Music]
julie i know a lot of people were
watching australia the first sign of any
possible trouble so i wasn't too too
concerned but i tell you i did get some
extra cash out of the atm
just in case the atms were shut down for
a couple of days after work occurred
and i made sure i wasn't in the plane
and i made sure i wasn't on the road
[Applause]
[Music]
ultimately though
at around one minute past 12 on new
year's day 2000.
the cell doors inside western
australia's maximum security prisons
remained firmly closed
uh it was it was on my mind until i fir
until we finished and started cracked
open the first beer
but i was happy to
you know not be around a lot of
technology and not being responsible for
a lot of technology
[Music]
we ended up finishing up at a party on
the top of a
parking garage i believe
[Music]
in the minutes and hours that followed
news bulletins carried no reports of
planes falling from the sky
large computer networks continued to
function
and while there were plenty of lost bank
cards
no one lost a bank account or saw their
bank balance wiped
whether this is entirely down to the
estimated 500 billion dollars spent
worldwide on making systems y2k
compliant
is well
something that's still open to debate
i can't recall any really major
incidents
i'm sure if we looked on wikipedia we
might find some
yeah so i look finally back on those
times
and i'm really thankful to the people
that that gave me the opportunity to
work there at the engineering company
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the y2k prison bug was written and
produced by rob mulhern with recordings
from tom gillespie special thanks to
matthew hackling and all our
contributors over the last 21 episodes
for more information on this episode and
all of the other 20 of course go to sky
news dot com forward slash storycast 21.
finally thanks to everyone who made this
series which was written produced and
sound mixed by rob mulhern research
recordings and digital by tom gillespie
archive with simon windsor the tv
treatments victoria hudson grant and
emily dieker the story consultant dave
terrace the design and graphics brian
gillingham and for social media chris
scott and sam gould
if you enjoyed the series or just one
particular episode please share comment
or rate on the platform of your podcast
provider
storycast will return again in 2022
i'm jane sekker thank you for listening
happy new year australia welcome to the
21st century on this magnificent night
the millennium night eternity over
sydney harbour
[Music]
[Music]
you